you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens hey everyone welcome back
to the game spot co-op stage here on the
show floor at e3 2016 I'm Lucy James
with along with Dave Jewett my esteemed
gamespot colleague we're joined by
matpat our esteemed guest oh man we're
back to a steamed in the final I'm
everything fine of the white esteemed
just a day 3 of e3 Maya my vote caps
gone hey it's a good adjective to you
yeah I feel like a steam gives us some
level of credibility which is nice this
time at midday yet so we got a shout out
for using the big words oh yeah this is
a genuine thing we do in the office is
that if you use a big word before midday
its prize yes we're running low Oh
clapper clap and a half all right go
we're here to talk about the biggest
surprises from this year's e3 good who
wants to kick off ooh well there's the
big one like the biggest surprise I
thing was the man himself spider-man ha
spider-man up Tony yes thank you as well
i did i do like spider-man I'm surprised
like he was making spider-man I thought
it would be sucker punch I genuinely
thought it was so I didn't mean to
differ i was just I didn't mean to dick
completely do you were building it up I
well I was just doing the little punch
line but now we've derail oh yeah spider
me look more about ya know please ain't
in you with your dramatic ville Jima yes
his his entrance was magnifique like I
do he knew everyone in that room that
was just ecstatic to see him and he just
walks that entire length down at the
music playing is Logan the background
cuz I'm back yeah everyone I'm back now
they're shocked it was perfect and then
now we saw the first look a death
stranding I Williams that I have no idea
what it is so I name and a weird game I
was like oh scared watching that trailer
that I was the resident evil one like I
felt genuinely uncomfortable NYC why's
he plugged into the baby hoping it's a
favorite dream was it because you saw
Norman Reedus is but as well because I
was like really kind of like somebody's
made an observation that is like an
allegory for Kojima's life like kajima
is Norman Reedus and he's the baby is
metal gear and he's connected to it and
then it gets taken away oh my
five male gears I was listen to be a
brat explain this last Lana's like bro
it's too late for this like it's it's
11pm you can't be blown my mind if I go
to bed who is this / I did that sounds
like a game theory episode I need to
talk to my purse look yo yeah oh boy
that know how the theory ah got the tag
line it but no one interesting about
death drowning is that it kijima he
always teases what he's doing right
saponin if you go back to his twitter
feed he's capitalizing d and ass yeah
and he was on Jeff Keeley's YouTube
gaming show just before the press
conference it was worried damn t-shirt
that said des yeah okay just really like
the old nintendo console the Diaz's did
you bring it back uh-huh he's a rebel
pony that's was in your games off no but
he I thought that intro was incredible
it was so it was actually quite
surprised I mean obviously his
appearance was surprising but the fact
that he had something to show yeah
because I guess in everyone's mind he
only got out of that right now so yeah
so we know that he's been touring the
country America's been touring the Sony
Studios to look at the tech look at what
everyone's working on so I know that
that was made in like a motion capture
studio that's I don't even think that's
go again men Janeiro yet but man if that
guy doesn't know how to build some hype
I mean here's here's my thought though
and and if you're kajima at this point
you're feeling a lot of pressure there's
a lot of hype around this project that
you're doing solo this is your big
effort you'd you know you've broken free
from the chains of you know your
corporate overlord and you're free to do
whatever you want you know your games
not gonna get turned into pachinko but
what helps you feel a little bit better
about things I don't know if you'd want
to turn this game into a pachinko
machine obviously days the middle babies
right all right oh but but it is one of
those things that like if you're him
like this is the make-or-break moment
for him like was the brilliance of metal
gear and all his past projects him being
kind of like reined in and kind of like
creatively shaped by a larger
corporation or was that truly like his
own baby like and now that he's set
loose to do whatever he wants is it
gonna will it have main treatments or is
it just too weird I like I think I'm
very curious to see what happened I
think
his name holds a lot of clout not today
he said he's built up around him so I
know that he was here at e3 and he had
Ken who's been his right-hand man for
years and years but also some members of
team silent weather yep walking around
with him so it could be like we don't
know anything about this game but the
talent that he's brought with him as
well as his incredible creative mind it
could be something brilliant like you
said we don't know anything about this
game but it doesn't exactly look like a
spiritual successor to Mel gear I can
never say being a spiritual successor to
the terrifying weird silent hill right
like if that's the new series we're
gonna get and obviously Norman Reedus
and like the whole PT thing yeah I be
hope for that as scared as I am for the
poor ago yes like it's still exciting
that he's kind of just been let off the
leash yeah yeah that's funny one of the
biggest surprise in his selfish he now
has the clout behind his own name and
the resources to just do what he murs
always wanted to do yeah II said he's
wanted to like get into movies as well
so I'm wondering whether or not this is
going to be a very cinematic and story
basics very well known that buddy sony
has a very um obviously have sony
pictures in whatever but the they have
powers the TV show remember that Shawn
Leighton can stop talking about a couple
years ago yeah I think season two lawns
not too long ago so I don't know if they
could potentially do something then
which would be quite interesting right
and especially as there's been more of a
push for game developers to become
entertainment studios like multimedia
entertainment studios with Ubisoft in
the assassins creed movie and watch dogs
movie you know yup lizard and warcraft
especially being a recent example I
could totally see that being or what was
a quantum quite a break right here where
was like this weird fusion of like video
game and like came out last a little
while ago yeah wasn't you long ago and I
comment but it was cool but like the TV
series is running alongside a right to
fire the fire yes yeah yeah I mean
they've already got like the fines was a
mistake maybe they're starting to learn
and they're starting to tie in these
universes I mean I'm not seen Warcraft
or Assassin's Creed but hopefully we're
past the point of the bad video game
movie tight yeah right um what else was
interesting from stoneys press
conference a big surprise so we kind of
knew the god of war leaked by
it's a completely new direction for it
had real last of us wives you've got old
man Kratos he's got a big beard but he
also has his son that comes around and I
think he accompanies you for the whole
game and it's not a fixed camera and go
anymore take a free phone camera that
doesn't seem to be as many cutie easy I
don't know it I'm gonna have to work
real hard so don't make that son really
annoying right yeah like it's gonna be
like the adoring fan from oblivion if
it's not done like just follow you
around like dad I'm thirsty yeah go and
drink some blood you don't kill a deer I
guess it's like it was a bees love tough
love in that trailer yeah well it
reminded me a lot of did you see the
revenant yes it remind me a lot of the
revenant we're like Leonardo kaprow to
his son is like you can't show them
weakness you have to do it this way let
me go crawl out of a dead horse bodies
one way moment about that is that like
there's still the old like Greek
elements to it yeah yes like he looks
very Valhalla now a viking wearing the
furs with the axe but he's still like
Spartan to his call that goes into
Spartan mode yeah so be interesting to
see like how it ties into like his his
child and and what kind of course are
gonna go through obviously very used to
seeing Kratos just be a one-man god of
war and just smashing into giant thing
so if he's got like jr. on one of those
like kid leashes that you see people
like how is he gonna be a little diving
up a giant Odinn to chop his head off
when like lil man Stan yeah you're gonna
McDonald's no I'm killing a god stop it
what I thought was interesting as well
is there was no naughty dog but we did
get uh days gone from Bend studio which
to be honest like I haven't played the
resident evil demo yet but days gone
kind of scared me more because it was
the relentless just absolute train of
not zombies they called freakers not a
zombie games week again right right like
you don't know mean it was like this
woman looks like never stop running neff
stop running and that's what would panic
me i guess i can't talking about
surprises what surprised me is the sheer
number of zombies of that game out of
screen real floors now which was really
impressive yeah did not stop coming like
what i was watching this game i was like
days gone more like Daisy gone cuz
this comes out like how amazing once
again mr. quip himself with it with
another good liner there well is all day
he's very good point like it's day three
of e3 and you're still cranking those
off I've got no fumes as soon as i'm off
stage was gonna fall over but beware i
feel you go over to the atlas booth and
yours will see i'm done give me a letter
/ soda bags i can fall asleep those uh
every year final fantasy has been
releasing those those land i am swag bag
I am that are literally human body size
like is there but they're practically
laughing yeah they're practically a
sleeping bag so there you go just grab
one of those curl up in the corner that
would be one of the surprises of e3 but
behind the like porn VR games your great
fantastic talking about most fries v3 I
was about to say talk about porn be our
biggest picking up I was surprised that
I should I pavia I was surprised what
are the things that surprised me III is
how much I loved Zelda both you and I
yeah my dad I think we're both like week
but soon as we're done we're dragging
you over there to play yeah I'm gonna be
on stage like half an hour after that oh
man this isn't looking good for me at
all damn it but you guys most loved it
yeah yeah and this year I mean it's
interesting cuz with God of War we just
talked about with Zelda this is the year
of like Witcher 3 but not really Witcher
3 but everyone feels like kind of a
Witcher game like everything's trying to
be a witch a game now and now wait it is
odd game right and now I know that's one
is a grave card game like I I played a
few games of that and it was great like
they've completely the gwent inside the
Wild Hunt was was out of fun yeah and
the story behind Gwen was like it was
just a passion project of like said that
one dude works on really I'd like loads
that like I have thousands thousands of
emails through the presentation that
they showed a supercut of all the tweets
and emails they went of ages and was
thousand early yeah it was just
literally a passion project that took
off and they have completely rebuilt it
redesigned it and I've went up seven
plane yesterday and I'm not massive into
these car game yeah that was some great
card Paul that was gonna be my thing
like and I saw my Twitter feed just blow
up with every meal of yours went when I
don't get it like that I never played it
in that which you three that's one of
the things that for me i like i love all
sorts of different games i try to play
as many things as possible they keep
familiar with all the different genres
and
card games I don't get it I I don't
understand the like enthusiasm for the
card games and so like if you guys can
educate me about like why why play a
virtual card game as opposed to like an
actual like tabletop version or
something like that like what is the
difference a real vision involves
talking to people we're not very good at
that okay fair enough we can do this at
home in the comfo yeah I got pajamas oh
no you can like use on your phone and
just use on the toilet you know nobody
mentioned it though it cuz whenever I
think card games my mind immediately
jumps to you you Oh which was like the
very first card game I was familiar with
which you know is it shows how lame i am
i yes I think that shows kind of like I
actually owned dueling Flav's do you
really really ask hey well done thanks
for admitting that out of Syria nobody
but it's funny cuz we just got done
talking about VR talking about card
games I I was at the oculus booth and I
got to play this one game with palmer
luckey founder of oculus which was
really really cool but the game the
loading screen was basically you're in a
wild west saloon you got to pick up
cards and throw them yeah what are you
just you talking about this just made me
something realize you could do in VR
actual like yugioh battles with the
glaive and everything and you can see
like the Blue Eyes White Dragon up here
in front of you that would be pretty
cool like that would convince me that
would convert me over to card games if
all of a sudden I was able to be like
you activated my trap card my black
magician there goes like okay new now in
public transpo and sound the tube yeah
amazing time did it do it did it did it
in a duel be possessed by the Pharaoh oh
wow oh I watched too much of that anime
i watch way too much there's no shame
hashtag no game this is a safe this is a
deep-space zone this is a safe ring I
don't know about the Internet duffel
that's another surprise of e3 I didn't
expect man Pat's talk about you give so
long I don't think anyone is surprising
me as well uh what are the surprises
were there so Ubisoft what do they even
have they had house Steve Steve was a
surprise it I guess hmm
I've never seen such a confusing no not
the thing is there is already a like a
skiing game first person called snow
uh-huh but from Ubisoft like I never i
don't know like words just for woods
yeah but I saw this I was like okay give
yourself that's cool but no seriously
make SSX tricky again oh my gosh are
they gonna are they gonna cut to this
scene where your buddy like it's
actually slammed against the rock and I
think yeah I think it's nothing is it
coming we might have missed it shoot but
but my favorite part of the trailer was
it's like a bunch of dudes and wingsuits
being like yeah let's have this awesome
race down the mountain and your bought
your buddy you see them just like take a
wrong turn there it is there it is tak
and it's like that guy's dead I'm sorry
but like what went from like let's have
fun with extreme sports we just
witnessed someone die right yeah that is
your buddy who is just very confused
trailer because it was like yeah extreme
sports let's go wild rad and then it was
like someone just died and then it was
like ah but let's take a moment to talk
about how beautiful nature is yeah like
bro so you can't have it all yeah I just
just Zone in on one piece yeah I will
say I'm impressed by the sheer scale
yeah and possibility of what you can do
in that game well I don't you know where
the game came from so I was talking to
the studio head from your fantasy and
she was explaining that obviously there
at the base of the Alps they all go
skiing and her all the time but what
they did is they took the tech from
Ghost Recon wildlands the mountains that
they'd made in that game okay and on
they had this old prototype for a jet
ski for some component for some other
years of game that they had they did you
just smack the two together and they
went are honest for some snow effects in
this presented it to you but something
like really yeah that's where the game
came from huh who's this annecy is a
supposed to do they typically they be
doing a lot of multiplayer so the
division they've been doing ghost recon
yeah Assassin's Creed they did for years
and years and years and now they do this
yeah it was surprising they ended the
conference on this though it is an odd
one to end I after kind of like a lot of
exciting stuff you know we all knew
watch dogs was coming and I think watch
dogs
trailer 1 over a lot of people yeah
that'll really charming trailer right
like I think a lot of people coming into
the S III we're skeptical about watch
dogs too after kind of like the lukewarm
reception that wash dogs one had the but
the hacking mechanic looks rejiggered
you know what you're able to do in the
world looks interesting the characters
San Francisco as a setting looks really
cool i think that 11 a lot of people
over it was sending more self
referential and more self-aware which is
what is the whole lot less energy than
right which was like my edge yeah yeah
but but then to go from that to steep it
was just kind of like this game that no
one really knows like we're having a
hard time talking about it i will say
like i was saying you know the ability
to hop between a lot of different camera
angles to rewind to flip to this other
guy to the second there's a lot of cool
possibility there and i think it's one
of those games that people like on
YouTube who kind of craft these you know
in game experiences and kind of make
meta games within the game will have a
lot of fun with and you can play a lot
with your friends is it a game that I
myself I'm gonna be like it I'm day 1
i'm gonna play this thing and be super
stoked about it not necessarily yeah I'm
excited to see what people can do with
it though we also saw from Ubisoft uh
trials and blood dragon combined in
together one finally so I'm that I'm a
big trials fan I didn't necessarily like
um not the one after the one that was on
like next-gen consoles that everything's
been locked off her small futuristic and
I completely the name escapes me you
know but what I like about the look of
trials of the Blood Dragon is that it's
its trials with different vehicles for
some reason you're on foot in some of
them you have a gun you're shooting and
it's also the wacky bizarro world of
blood dragon 2 dean evans who's
acreditar creative director on that i
was like what is that guy working on
because it's either gonna be you know
like dinosaur dlc for far cry primal
which doesn't seem to be getting any
post release content but i am super glad
that it's in a franchise like Charles
yeah when when it was announced like I I
just wanted to go back to egg let them
play that game but unfortunately now
I've been reading reviews but apparently
it's not that great no really really
like I was talking to you the guys have
played it yeah
from upstairs and I war room and they
were saying that most the game isn't
even on a bike anymore oh yeah they're
like never like got rabotu formulas and
maybe like mismeasured yeah the the
amounts they've put in like I'm still
gonna try it i'm still gonna give it a
go but made my hives died down a little
bit for it seems to be getting mixed
thoughts oh that's this morning yeah but
it seemed mad franchises that you think
would gel together in a way and in a
sweet way and especially with all the
pomp and circumstance that the
announcement god with that kind of
having that like 90s error like wrestler
intro and kind of like the crazy pants
with like the fire and this and that i
was really excited about and that's
that's unfortunate yeah i'm still like i
said i'm still gonna give it a go sure
of course we're gonna give it a try but
maybe just don't go in expecting just on
your bike right time i think i think
it's a it's a little less about to let
less trials more blood dragon then it is
just a blood dragon version of trials
yeah yeah see what else i loved the look
of which is C of Thieves yeah I didn't
know what to expect from that guy yeah
like it was they were doing like a
priority thing so of course obviously
your mind goes to Monkey Island it goes
to Assassin's Creed for sid meier's
pirates in life ignorance get rid we can
we have a shout out though to this year
real quick the and they're playing it on
screen right now the just like awkward
voiceover like gameplay trailers where
it's scripted but not really scripted oh
the Ghost Recon wildlands trailer was
the absolute worst for that there there
was a lot of that this year where it's
like hey this is a picture and picture
thing so we can relate to you YouTube
gamers and it was just very much like yo
ho look at us go and at least of this or
these things we're having fun wearing
yeah it was just like the driest
scripted banter ever although I think
there was one moment in here where
someone was like saying like nom nom nom
nom nom and they were like spinning like
a pirate wheel or something so like the
audio didn't sync up it was that just
awkward moment of like oh hey no I
really love look maybe you have you
played love is in a dangerous space-time
yes yes kinda i'm getting that vibe so
that where you have to work together
with people to try and do stuff but this
looks like it's really fun like funny
and like you don't know what's gonna
happen you ever attack on the people you
can go get drunk yeah come back to the
ship yeah welp I mean pirate
was in general like we have for honor
which we talked about which is samurais
nights and Vikings great finally we're
getting back to pirates right like this
is an era that like assassin's creed 4
was the one with pirates yeah that was a
really great game in what and so you
know to actually live the life of like a
pirate and have a game where you're
playing around with a crew of your you
know fellow mates that's exciting and
it's good to see gaming get back to to
fun games like to me that was the thing
that was sorely missing in a lot of this
year's e3 and I really appreciate it
when it was shown was a sense of fun
yeah a lot of games that were showcased
for like you know gritty
post-apocalyptic future or like techie
we got to take down the corporate
overlords Oh to see sticka are not stick
of truth fractured butthole you know
you're on screen and just be like a
light comedic takedown of superhero
franchises to see you know see if these
show up and it's like here's a bright
colorful game that's you know harkens
back to a wind waker stuff like that
like those moments really stood out to
me in a sea of you know just generally
darker more serious games yeah which is
why I referenced em rabba focus
obviously they've just been like i said
before they've yeah just been stuck
doing Kinect games or like they did
their rare replay elation it seems like
they've been aching for another chump of
a bit like like you said before put me
in coach like yeah we're ere we can make
fun game yeah like everyone when I saw
the trailer all I was thinking is we
need to get this game in the game spot
office and we need to make the game spot
pirate crew and just have a pirate big
Jew but we will have a holodeck and a
pirate rule now gamespot is like the
coolest place to work ever you know we'd
ok ok let me like we like to me let's
give a fun holiday expiratory thought to
sink your ship though you're okay I'm
just gonna join your guys's crew what
does em clean up poop deck thank you
thank you thank you for that hey I'll
work my way through the ranks exactly i
feel like the poop deck is like the mail
the like mail room of pirate exactly
yeah hiram or cook and swap in the day
ya llevo and then leave my god i'm so
what if what are your absolutely
highlights me three what's the big thing
you're gonna you go home what people say
to you what did you see the best what
was the best thing in e3 we're gonna say
well
I'm gonna say it's gonna be it's gonna
be Zelda is it just it just it was left
field for me I was never that big into
Zelda and what's amazing about it is
that literally everyone I've spoken to
has a different story yeah Doyle is that
impressive they have a different story
about 45 minute demo yep so when that
game is out it's just it's gonna blow
people away out there yep for me it's
now that I agree uh so for me I think my
number one has got to be PlayStation VR
like we talked about before and all the
experiences that that has to offer and
then followed up by Zelda though those
two were far and away the things that
got me most excited as a gamer you know
I'm excited for all the possibility and
adventuring that Zelda has to offer I'm
excited about all the possibility for
just gaming in general that VR has to
offer for me um I didn't I didn't get a
chance to see Zelda but what I did
finally get to see is gameplay from
persona 5 I cannot wait like it still
doesn't have a UK release date but you
know it is coming in the West it is
coming to America it's definitely being
localized so you know we'll just bide
our time but seeing my game in action
after persona 4 was walked 2008 mm-hmm
is something really really special but
thank you but Dave join me in thanking
Matt for coming on our stage thank you
incredible thanks for putting up with me
for two hours it's full hasn't felt like
two hours right time it felt like four
but guys for more coverage from e3 2016
on the game spot co-op stage make sure
you don't go anywhere we've got critical
role coming up next thank you for
joining us have a great three awesome
you